hi guys this is Victor with DIY time and
today we're gonna be programming a spare
key using a technique that works with
pretty much any Toyota Camry equipped
with immobilizer system and for that
we're gonna be using tech stream cable
and software compatible with Toyota
vehicles if you need to know where to
find one of those check out the link in
inscription we're gonna use this cable
to connect Windows laptop computer to
the obd2 port under the steering wheel
use your original master key and then
turn it to the on position
launch the text dream software and then
connect to your vehicle select
immobilizer category on the main menu
and then click on utility button select
cue registration read the welcome
message and then click Next
step 1 remove the key from the ignition
cylinder then insert the key back into
the ignition cylinder and turn it on
click Next when you're ready step 2
within 20 seconds remove the master key
from the ignition cylinder click Next
step 3 within 10 seconds insert the new
blank key that you are trying to program
and click Next
now we just need to wait for 75 seconds
until the new key is registered in the
car ECU
and you're gonna receive confirmation
and the key registration is complete you
can program additional keys by clicking
next otherwise click on exit to wrap up
the registration process you can test
your new key using security light for
their mobilizer system if key is not
present in the ignition cylinder this
slide will be blinking constantly if you
insert properly registered key for this
car the light should disappear after you
successfully tested your new key you can
take it to your local hardware store and
have them caught the Keyblade to match
the pattern on your original master key
now let's take a look at how to program
the remote buttons we are gonna go back
to the main menu and this time we're
gonna select main body category click on
utility button and then select wireless
code registration before you begin
insert the master key and turn it to the
on position next open and unlock the
driver's side door and leave all other
doors closed step 1
review remaining number of remotes that
can be registered in my case I have two
remotes currently registered and I can
add up to five more remotes
click Next in step two you can preview
the registration procedure click Next
when you're ready step 3
on the remote transmitter push lock and
unlock simultaneously for one second
within three seconds pressing their lock
or unlock button again for one second
wireless code registration is complete
click Next if you'd like to add more
remotes otherwise click exit now you can
try to lock and unlock doors to test
your newly program your remote if you're
not able to program your new key for
some reason please visit this webpage
where I'm trying to answer the most
frequently asked questions that's it I
hope this video was helpful if you'd
like to see more Toyota and Lexus repair
videos like this please subscribe to my
channel thank you for watching and have
a nice day